J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Ça allait tout le monde, j'espère que vous allez bien. Mes sincères excuses pour ces longs mois de pause depuis le dernier épisode de Septante Minutes Avec, avec Myriam Leroy.
Chaque année, quand je démarre une nouvelle saison, je me promets que cette année, je serai intransigeant, je serai super discipliné et je sortirai un épisode toutes les deux semaines.
Mais figurez-vous que ça ne dépend pas seulement de moi, ça dépend aussi de,
déjà toutes mes autres responsabilités et aussi le fait que parfois, les invités me font faux bond, ce qui m'est arrivé à plusieurs reprises, ces dernières semaines.
Ça n'excuse en rien, mais ça explique un petit peu l'état des choses.
Tout ça pour dire que Septante Minutes Avec reprend, que de nouveaux épisodes sont prévus jusqu'au mois de juillet, et que plein de super sujets seront traités et je vous en parlerai plus à la fin de cet épisode.
Cette semaine, je reçois Ihsane Haouach, que vous connaissez peut-être parce qu'elle avait fait les grands titres dans les médias en 2021,
lorsqu'elle avait été nommée commissaire du gouvernement auprès de l'Institut pour l'égalité des femmes et des hommes, mais qu'il y avait eu quelques polémiques autour de, notamment, son port de foulard.
Elle fait aussi plein d'autres choses, y compris écrire des livres. Et on s'est d'ailleurs retrouvés avec elle en mars dernier pour parler de son nouveau livre qui s'appelle Open Up Your Organization et qui sort ce mois-ci en anglais.
C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Ihsane Haouach. Bonjour Ihsane.
Bonjour.
Ihsane, est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour celles et ceux qui ne te connaissent pas encore ?
Alors, donc je suis Ihsane Haouach. Je suis une entrepreneuse sociétale de trente-sept, presque trente-huit ans. Je suis essentiellement engagée dans les transformations éthiques et durables.
Donc j'ai le privilège en quelque sorte d'avoir un pied dans différents mondes, à savoir à la fois le secteur privé, le secteur social et également le secteur public.
OK. La façon dont cette interview s'est organisée est un petit peu particulière, puisqu'en fait, tu as écouté l'épisode avec Kaoutar Boustani et Sanae Djilil y a...
Un an et demi.
C'était il y a un an et demi, ouais, c'est ça, oui. Et en fait, j'étais très surpris de voir, après que j'aie publié cet épisode, puisqu'on parlait de toi, en fait,
rapidement, à plusieurs reprises dans cet épisode.
Très surpris de recevoir un message de ta part. Et je t'avais dit : « Mais, en fait, j'ai monté cet épisode parce qu'il y avait ce, l'affaire Ihsane Haouach dont on va parler dans les médias.
» Et mais j'avais vu que voilà, tu t'étais retirée de... Tu ne pouvais plus t'exprimer dans la presse.
Et donc, je ne t'avais même pas invitée. J'avais directement essayé d'aborder les questions que tout ça abordait, voilà, mais avec d'autres intervenantes du coup.
Et aujourd'hui, tu reviens sous les projecteurs. Qu'est-ce qui explique ce choix ? Pourquoi maintenant ?
En fait, déjà, j'avais eu besoin de temps pour pouvoir me reconstruire, pouvoir digérer ce qui s'est passé.
J'avais besoin de prendre soin de moi, de prendre un peu de temps off, parce que ça avait été des semaines assez intenses.
Et puis, j'ai toujours eu une parole publique. J'ai toujours eu un engagement pour une société plus inclusive.
Et ça, ça date pas d'hier. J'ai notamment créé mes propres structures aussi au niveau associatif, et toujours essayé de faire du changement aussi en entreprise.
Et donc, j'avais besoin vraiment de ce temps pour réfléchir. Et puis, j'avais envie aussi d'écrire.
C'est un projet qui était là depuis longtemps. Et je me suis formée en écriture créative. Et du coup, ça m'a aidée à pouvoir écrire.
Et puis j'avais envie d'écrire un management book. Et c'est comme ça qu'est né le projet. Et donc pour écrire, c'est bien d'être dans sa petite bulle, seule.
OK.
J'ai aussi été dans, voilà, un peu dans les Ardennes ou autre pour vraiment pouvoir me ressourcer. J'avais vraiment besoin de calme, d'être avec moi-même, avec les arbres, avec ma famille aussi.
Et puis, j'ai commencé à me rendre compte petit à petit que ce qui m'était arrivé, c'était surtout virtuel et que finalement, dans la vie de tous les jours, le monde n'est pas si agressif que ça.
Ça, sur un terrain de jeu, un terrain de jeu virtuel, mais des conséquences quand même physiques ou bien est-ce que globalement, c'était virtuel et ça n'a pas d'impact sur toi ?
Ben, en fait, c'est compliqué quand on vit la chose parce qu'il y a l'aspect vraiment sur les réseaux sociaux. Puis moi, il y avait quand même l'aspect aussi assez médiatique, qui...
Enfin, je veux dire, j'étais la une de la presse pendant six semaines. Et donc là, c'est aussi sur la presse papier.
C'était des débats au Parlement, à la Chambre. C'était... Et donc dans la rue, on m'abordait, on me posait des questions.
Et je savais jamais trop si on voulait du bien ou du mal. Et puis j'étais juste complètement, enfin, épuisée mentalement.
Oui, c'est ça. D'où mon étonnement quand tu dis que c'était globalement assez virtuel.
Ben, ce qui s'est passé, c'est que quand ça s'est calmé au niveau de la presse, finalement, ben on a commencé à moins en parler.
Et donc il reste des trolls qui continuent à m'attaquer encore aujourd'hui et qui, de toute façon, m'attaqueront quoi que je fasse ou que je ne fasse pas.
Je veux dire, on m'attaquait pour des choses où j'étais déjà absente, j'étais absolument pas concernée. Et donc, moi, quand j'avais été sélectionnée dans un programme qui s'appelle les Forty Under Forty.
Donc c'est une sélection de quarante leaders en dessous de quarante ans qui pourraient penser à améliorer la Belgique.
Et donc le programme commençait en octobre pour moi. Donc c'était juste après les événements. Et ça m'a énormément aidée parce qu'au début, j'ai failli ne pas y aller, me désinscrire.
Alors, et là, mon mari me disait : « Mais attends, c'était une sélection de dingue. Il y avait plus de mille candidates.
T'en fais partie. Il faut y aller, il faut y aller. »
Et qu'est-ce qui faisait que tu voulais te désinscrire ?
Parce que je voulais voir personne.
OK, oui, c'est un-
J'avais l'impression que tout le monde me voulait du mal et donc je voulais plus voir personne. Et voilà. Et finalement, voilà, surtout sur l'impression de mes proches, c'était : « Mais vas-y ».
Donc j'ai été, je me rappelle la première fois que j'avais été à ce forum, j'étais vraiment dans mon coin. J'avais peur qu'on vienne encore me parler de ça.
Et en fait, j'ai été accueillie super positivement. C'est-à-dire que les gens venaient, on me disait : « Ah, toi, t'es notre héroïne.
J'avais trop hâte de te rencontrer quand j'ai vu que tu étais avec nous dans le programme ». Et c'était super positif, c'était des câlins, c'était : « Oh, j'ai vraiment admiré.
T'as une dignité dans tout ce qui s'est passé ». Et je me suis dit : « Ah ben en fait, finalement, les gens dans la vraie vie ne voient pas les choses comme moi je l'ai perçu et je pensais que c'était-
C'est intéressant parce qu'on reçoit en fait surtout les messages hyper négatifs, hyper toxiques. Et puis finalement, on est presque surpris quand on reçoit des messages, ben, pleins d'amour et de soutien.
Parce qu'en fait, y compris nous, on a moins le réflexe en fait d'exprimer ces choses-là positivement, d'envoyer des messages à, je sais pas, les créateurs de contenu pour leur dire qu'on aime bien ce qu'on fait.
Ouais, y a un biais à ce niveau-là. Et donc, tu expliquais que tu t'étais mise en retrait dans les Ardennes pour écrire ton livre.
Donc ton livre qui s'appelle Open Up Your Organization.
Oui.
Donc OPEN, qui est donc les initiales de Openness, le Pa-
Patience
Patience, Empathy et Natural. Donc un livre qui, pour l'instant, est uniquement en anglais.
Oui.
Donc, on enregistre ce podcast en mars. La sortie prévue en mai, donc quelques semaines ou très peu de temps après la parution de cet épisode.
Donc un livre qui est globalement quand même assez marqué dans le milieu professionnel. Tu parlais des Forty Under 40.
On reste un peu dans
cette culture-là. Tu disais que tu t'étais mise en retrait pour écrire ce livre, mais tu as aussi, en fait, fait beaucoup de rencontres et tu as interrogé, voilà, Ibrahim Ouassari, Thierry Geerts, etc.
Donc c'est pas seulement une expérience qui s'est faite en retrait.
Tout à fait. Donc, ben, je suis un être fondamentalement, comme tous les êtres humains, un être sociable et social.
Et ce qu'il y a, c'est que j'ai gardé le projet vraiment secret. Donc même les personnes que je voulais interviewer, je leur disais : « Tu ne dis rien à personne ».
Déjà, j'étais même pas sûre d'arriver au bout.
OK.
Voilà, et toujours un peu ce mythe autour de l'auteur. On a l'impression que voilà-
Syndrome de l'imposteur ou ?
Oui, clairement, syndrome de l'imposteur. Et puis aussi, on a l'impression qu'on doit toujours choisir entre le volet littéraire et scientifique.
Et moi, j'ai les deux, j'aime les deux, j'aime les sciences et j'aime le littéraire.
OK.
Et donc on a l'impression qu'on ne peut pas être compétent dans les deux parce que c'est l'un ou l'autre. Alors moi, j'ai toujours été active dans l'énergie et je continue à l'être.
Et donc c'est un volet de ma vie qui est très important. Et puis j'avais ce besoin et cette envie d'écrire. Et ce que j'ai fait, c'est que, 'fin, je suis plus dans le fait de raconter des histoires.
Je voulais pas écrire un livre académique. Je pense qu'il y en a plein qui ont été écrits là-dessus et qu'il y a des gens,
voilà, très intelligents qui travaillent dans les universités, dans les centres de recherche, qui peuvent faire ce genre de bouquins.
Moi, je voulais vraiment partir dans mon expérience vécue
et j'avais envie aussi de me nourrir d'expériences vécues d'autres personnes qui sont dans des positions de management et d'avoir aussi une diversité dans le pool, en quelque sorte, de personnes que j'allais interviewer.
Donc, comme tu as cité, Ibrahim Ouassari, Thierry Geerts, donc CEO de Google Belgique. Il y a aussi Irem Kadri, CEO de Solvay.
Il y a aussi Isabelle Ferreira, qui était, quand je l'ai interviewée, la présidente de l'Académie royale des sciences de Belgique.
Et donc, il y a toute une série de personnes dont je voulais aussi écouter leur vision et leur vécu et la partager ensemble.
Mh. Et
donc, tu expliquais que tu voulais mélanger à la fois l'aspect narratif et scientifique.
Effectivement, ton livre, il y a beaucoup à la fois du storytelling, des expériences que tu as vécues, et on va revenir sur certaines d'entre elles,
et en même temps, du
du trait, du logique, du raisonnement, du qu'est-ce qui...
Et ce qui est particulièrement intéressant, je trouve, comme approche, c'est que tu défends une vision sur la diversité, l'inclusivité, mais tu le fais surtout
dans un prisme qui est corporate, pour dire ça comme ça, avec l'idée de dire
: « D'accord, tout ça, c'est le bien, mais je vais surtout ici défendre l'idée selon laquelle tout ça, c'est bénéfique dans une vision managériale, dans une vision de productivité. »
Ouais.
Pourquoi ce choix-là et pourquoi pas, je sais pas, tu aurais pu écrire un livre vraiment de politique politicienne sur la façon dont notre société devrait aborder ces questions, etc.
Et non, toi, tu choisis vraiment de le faire dans le cadre LinkedIn, en fait.
Oui. Alors, il y a, c'est Richard Manson, qui disait : « Doing good is good for business. »
Ouais, tu ouvres le livre très tôt avec cette quote-là.
Alors, moi, c'est quelque chose dont je suis convaincue parce que j'aime pas l'aspect moralisateur, je veux dire, et ça marche pas de toute façon.
De leur dire : « Le racisme, c'est pas bien, le sexisme, c'est pas bien ». OK, OK. Mais les gens se rendent pas forcément compte d'actes qui peuvent être racistes et qui peuvent vraiment porter atteinte vraiment
au bien-être physique et mental des individus.
Je pense que le prisme économique, le prisme de dire : « Tu vas faire quelque chose de bien et en même temps, tu vas gagner de l'argent avec.
» C'est un peu le côté, comment on dit en anglais : « What's in it for me ? » OK, je vais aussi gagner quelque chose là-dedans.
Tu montres la carotte.
Voilà. Et donc, je pense que c'est comme ça qu'on y arrive. Et au moins avec ça, on n'est pas dans la moralisation. Et au moins avec ça aussi, je pense que quand les gens, ils le font,
il n'y a pas ce côté de recherche de gratitude absolue et de dire : « Voilà, j'ai tendu la main à quelques jeunes et je les ai recrutés, donc ils me doivent leur vie.
» Et ça, je veux pas non plus. Je veux pas ce côté aussi où on se dit : « Voilà, ben tu me dois tout, parce que je t'ai aidée, je suis venue te chercher, je l'ai fait par pur désintérêt ».
Non, il y a aussi un intérêt financier derrière. Il y a un intérêt à avoir plus d'inclusion dans la société, entreprise et dans la société de manière générale.
Et comme les sociétés et les entreprises sont une partie importante de notre vie, je pense que c'est assez intéressant comme enseignement parce que si là,
et je pense que le monde privé est plus agile et plus flexible, il sera plus rapide aussi à implémenter des choses.
D'ailleurs, Thierry Geerts, à un moment donné, dit dans mon livre que
lui, ben il a la chance que comme il est CEO de sa boîte, le jour où il décide quelque chose, eh ben il décide le vendredi, le lundi, il commence l'implémentation,
alors qu'au niveau politique, tu peux pas décider seul, tu peux pas avancer, tu avanceras très lentement, ça va prendre plus de temps.
Mais si on arrive à changer les choses dans cet aspect-là de la vie, on peut le changer aussi au niveau de la société.
Donc le privé a plus de flexibilité pour faire des changements rapides, là où-
Ouais.
Là où quand on est, voilà, commissaire pour l'égalité des genres ou ce genre de choses, peut-être plus difficile d'avoir des effets rapides.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. C'est clair.
OK, OK. C'est intéressant comme axe. Donc, cette vision de société. Arrivons-y. Arrivons-y. Donc, quatre valeurs prônées à travers ce livre.
La première qui est donc l'ouverture, openness. Les exemples que tu cites évidemment à travers le livre de ta vie personnelle, de tes expériences professionnelles,
il y a évidemment beaucoup de choses qui tournent autour de comment tu es perçue, les intentions qu'on te prête, les expériences qu'on te prête.
Tu cites un exemple à un moment donné d'une personne qui voit un chariot de ménage sur son chemin et qui s'adresse à toi.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il te dit ?
Ça, c'était ma première année professionnelle en plus. Ça faisait seulement six mois que je pense que je travaillais dans l'entreprise et je travaillais tard.
J'ai toujours été un peu workaholic. Et il me dit... Il sort des toilettes et moi, je vais pour rentrer dans les toilettes.
Il me dit : « Madame, merci d'enlever ce chariot d'ici ». Et je le regarde et je comprends pas trop sur le moment.
Le quelques secondes d'hésitation, je me dis : « Mais déjà, pour qui il se prend de me parler comme ça et pourquoi il me demande ça ?
» Sachant que les personnes qui font le ménage ont un costume quoi, ils ont leur petite veste, enfin, ils sont reconnaissables.
Et moi, j'avais une tunique en soie. Donc, et je me disais : c'est quand même dingue parce que malgré le fait que j'avais une tunique en soie d'une certaine marque,
je suis là en tant que travailleuse, en tant que cadre dans cette entreprise.
J'étais identifiée comme les Young Professional of Tomorrow, donc les jeunes professionnels qu'on voyait comme futurs leaders de l'entreprise très vite.
Et malgré ça, on pense que si je suis là, c'est uniquement pour faire le ménage. Et ça, ça m'a fait mal et je voulais pas tomber non plus dans le truc de se dire : Ah ben les femmes de ménage sont en dessous de moi, etc.
Non, j'aime pas déjà cette logique-là. Donc déjà, je pense que n'importe qui qui travaille mérite un respect. Et donc la façon qu'il avait de parler, même si j'étais la femme de ménage, il l'avait pas parlé comme ça.
Et le fait qu'il méprise pour ça. Et donc du coup, j'ai eu quelques secondes d'hésitation, je le regardais. Et donc lui, il était encore plus agacé parce qu'il voyait que je n'obéissais pas à ses ordres.
Et il insiste. Et puis je lui dis : « Ben, je dis : ben tu peux le pousser toi s'il te dérange, au moins, tu serviras à quelque chose ».
Et puis je suis rentrée aux toilettes. Et je me suis dit : Mais c'est pas possible quoi. Et donc lui, il est resté choqué.
Et donc après, le lendemain, j'ai été demander autour : « Tiens, j'ai rencontré un type comme ça hier soir.
Tu sais c'est qui ? » J'ai essayé de trouver dans quel département il était et faire passer le message.
Pour te venger ou quoi ?
Pas pour me venger, pour faire passer le message de manière indirecte, pour que ses collègues lui fassent passer le message et qu'il se sente mal, qu'il se rende compte la prochaine fois qu'il veut pas le faire.
OK. Donc qu'il y ait une conséquence quoi, à ce comportement.
C'est ça. C'était pas un-- Je cherchais pas à lui faire un blâme, mais juste une sensibilisation.
Donc quand tu prends cette valeur d'ouverture, c'est très clairement sur le constat que à l'heure actuelle, de manière générale, l'environnement professionnel, l'environnement corporate était fermé à la diversité.
C'est ça le constat que tu poses ?
C'est vraiment, ça dépend vraiment des entreprises. Je dirais de manière générale, on pourrait clairement faire mieux, et ça dépend des entreprises.
Les entreprises-- Et même dans une entreprise, ça dépend du département dans lequel on est. Donc moi, j'ai vécu des cultures d'entreprises très différentes en fonction des départements dans lesquels j'étais.
Et c'est clair que, en tout cas au niveau des organes de gestion, ça manque clairement de diversité. Au niveau du recrutement des gens, ça manque en général aussi.
Et puis il y a aussi différentes formes de diversité. Donc par exemple, souvent aujourd'hui, quand on parle de diversité, on va parler de ce que j'appellerais plutôt la mixité, donc les hommes et les femmes.
Hum.
C'est bien, c'est une chose, mais c'est pas suffisant. Ou bien par exemple, j'avais, il y a un startupper que j'ai interviewé dans mon livre, Michael Bornaud, qui disait : « Ben moi, quand j'ai créé ma boîte, j'étais fier.
On s'est dit : nous, on va chercher la complémentarité des compétences. » Et ils étaient super fiers d'avoir une équipe diverse.
Et puis ils se rendent compte après qu'en fait tout le monde a autour de vingt-cinq ans, parce que c'était une boîte dans le digital.
Et donc ils se sont rendus compte qu'ils n'avaient pas de diversité d'âge.
C'est parfois un challenge, en particulier dans le digital, d'aller chercher les personnes plus âgées, d'aller chercher des femmes quand les pipelines de formation sont assez biaisés-
Ouais, tout à fait.
Dans le pourcent d'hommes, ce genre de choses.
C'est ça. Ben ça remonte à l'éducation. Après, très souvent-- Donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut travailler déjà en amont. Mais je veux dire, on va pas attendre de révolutionner le système éducatif pour travailler sur l'inclusion.
En général, ce qui marche, c'est d'avoir en quelque sorte la première. OK ? La première, c'est un peu plus difficile. Et puis après, ça montre une ouverture, ça montre, on ouvre aussi un nouveau réseau.
Donc le recrutement, c'est beaucoup par réseau, même trop par réseau, selon moi. Et donc voilà, une fois qu'on a quelqu'un qui est issu de certains quartiers, ben on va avoir plus de visibilité.
Notre entreprise va avoir plus de visibilité dans ce quartier-là et donc on va pouvoir recruter plus. Donc c'est toujours-- Je pense qu'il faut continuer à forcer, forcer le trait pour que ça arrive.
Et donc, en particulier, si on parle d'ouverture, si on parle de tolérance pour appeler ça comme ça, d'inclusivité,
j'aimerais qu'on parle de la façon dont les, voilà, en l'occurrence les femmes musulmanes qui portent le foulard sont perçues, sont incluses ou pas assez incluses dans les environnements professionnels.
Donc
moi, je suis mais absolument ignorant en la matière. Est-ce que--
Quelle est ta perspective là-dessus ? Est-ce que--
Donc on a donné les exemples et il y en a beaucoup dans ton livre hein, de personnes qui te disent que tu n'es pas à ta place, qui, avant même de te connaître, présument que tu n'es pas à ta place.
Le constat, il est assez clair et je pense que personne ne va le remettre en question. Personne n'est censé en tout cas.
Mais quelle est, de ton point de vue, la racine de tout ça ? Qu'est-ce qui cause cette injustice et discrimination en particulier ?
Mais je pense, c'est comme, enfin c'est comme tout, c'est comme le racisme de manière générale. Donc ça ne vise pas essentiellement les femmes musulmanes qui portent le foulard.
C'est un des, je dirais, c'est une des causes supplémentaires de discrimination, mais c'est souvent la méconnaissance.
Donc si je connais pas, ben j'ai une idée sur la personne, c'est les stéréotypes, c'est humain. Tout le monde a des stéréotypes.
La question, c'est comment est-ce qu'on arrive à les dépasser. Quelquefois, ben, on refuse, voilà, sur base de l'apparence,
mais au fur et à mesure, si on rencontre la personne, si on travaille avec,
quelquefois parce qu'on n'a pas le choix et c'est pour ça dans le cas dont je traite dans mon livre, c'est de se dire ben voilà, j'aime pas telle personne parce qu'elle est de telle origine ou parce que voilà.
Et si je suis obligée de travailler avec, je vais dépasser ce biais, ce biais de l'apparence. Et donc c'est là-dessus où je vais vraiment travailler sur l'inclusion.
Et au début, ça va commencer avec cette fameuse remarque que quasi chaque personne racisée a déjà entendu une fois dans sa vie, c'est : oui, mais toi, ça va, mais les autres.
Et donc déjà, ça, c'est horrible de dire ça parce que je veux dire, c'est indigne de toute une identité. Moi, je le prends pas du tout comme un compliment quand on me dit ça et je suis pas la seule.
Mais ça commence avec ça et puis finalement, c'est : ah ok, la prochaine fois que je vois une femme qui porte le foulard, ben je me rends compte finalement que ça me pose pas vraiment de problème.
Et quand on voit d'ailleurs dans le débat public, les gens qui prennent position par rapport à ça sont souvent des gens qui n'ont pas vraiment d'expérience en entreprise et qui pensent que ça pose problème.
Mais dans les faits, ça ne pose pas de problème. Moi, j'ai travaillé dix ans dans une entreprise privée. J'ai même géré des projets internationaux, j'ai été chef de département.
J'ai travaillé avec aussi des directeurs, y compris à Paris, où la logique de la neutralité est encore tout autre.
On pense au début que ça pose un problème, mais ça ne pose aucun problème dans les faits. Dans les faits, il n'y a pas de problème et je ne suis pas la seule à pouvoir en témoigner.
Et donc aujourd'hui, de plus en plus de femmes qui portent le foulard arrivent à trouver leur propre chemin dans le marché de l'emploi, essentiellement dans le domaine privé, mais également public.
Et on se rend compte finalement que les idées préconçues, ben ça, finalement, ça ne pose pas de problème. Il est où le problème ?
Et j'ai eu beaucoup ce genre de discussions. Tiens, au début, j'aurais cru que, mais finalement, voilà. Et surtout que nous, on fait encore plus attention.
Moi, je veux dire avec mes collègues, les débats politiques, je rentre jamais dedans. Les débats religieux, j'évite.
Dès qu'on me pose une question sur telle ou telle chose, je me dis : ah là là, moi, si je dis un truc, ça va être si tu-- donc maintenant avec l'affaire Haouach de l'an passé, c'est encore pire.
Mais déjà avant, déjà avant, je me disais toujours : ok, même si c'est pendant la pause déjeuner, je fais attention parce que je me dis, je vais dire la moindre chose et ça va être : ah, elle a dit ça, c'est de la propagande, c'est ci, c'est ça.
Donc on fait encore plus attention à ne pas parler de religieux ou de politique au travail.
Oui, au travail. C'est vraiment que tu t'expliques que tu es, tu fus, tu étais
particulièrement prudente et particulièrement réticente à exprimer tes opinions parce que tu avais peur que ce soit
voilà catalogué, que ce soit résumé, que ta position soit prise pour être comme étant celle de toutes les femmes qui portent le foulard ainsi de suite.
Et puis finalement, ton opinion, ta prise de position, tu l'as faite, tu l'as faite, mais pas qu'un peu quoi. Tu-- donc c'est, qu'est-ce qui explique ce changement de façon de-
Ben parce que je me suis fait attaquer, je me suis fait énormément attaquer. Donc comme je disais, j'étais à la une de tous les journaux pendant cinq semaines, j'avais des appels-
Non mais donc ça, c'est-- là, tu expliques ton vécu quand tu étais voilà commissaire à l'Institut pour l'Égalité femmes-hommes.
Donc il y a eu un changement à un moment donné.
Il y a eu à un moment donné, ça, c'est plus quand j'ai lancé des initiatives sociétales où j'ai commencé à un peu plus aller dans la presse parce qu'on me contactait.
Et j'avoue que j'ai vite arrêté parce que je me rendais compte qu'on m'appelait que pour le foulard.
Et moi, je disais, j'ai envie de parler-- j'avais créé une association qui s'appelle TEEN, on travaillait sur le développement des jeunes et je voulais parler de ça.
Je voulais parler de comment, voilà, les jeunes des quartiers, on peut, voilà, travailler avec eux, les former, qu'est-ce qui manque dans le système éducatif actuel, etc.
Et donc on m'invitait quelquefois pour parler en disant oui, voilà, en tant que cofondatrice de TEEN. Et puis j'arrive et puis foulard, bam.
Et alors du coup, au début ben, voilà, je me faisais un peu avoir dans le sens où je faisais pas attention, j'étais un peu naïve.
Alors, il faut se dire aussi que moi, mes expériences associatives, à la base, c'était du bénévolat sur mon temps libre.
Et donc j'avais un emploi à temps plein. Et puis j'avais ça à côté que je faisais pendant mes temps de midi, mes soirées, mes week-ends.
Et puis du coup, quand j'arrivais à un débat où au début, j'allais de bonne foi, ben j'avais pas la préparation, par exemple, d'une personnalité politique ou d'un chroniqueur que j'allais avoir en face de moi.
Et donc il y a ça aussi qui jouait, c'est-à-dire que je disais, mais en fait, je suis pas à égalité parce que moi, ben c'est pas mon métier de venir parler.
Mon métier, c'est de faire et ça, ça a toujours été. Et c'est pour ça qu'à un moment donné, j'ai dit : ok, j'arrête. Parce que finalement, vous m'appelez que pour le foulard.
Appelez-moi, s'il vous plaît, pour parler des jeunes et là, je serai là. Et donc là, j'avais moins d'invitations.
Ensuite, en tant que commissaire du gouvernement, c'était une fonction qui était censée, c'était quasi du bénévolat, c'était à peine rémunéré et c'était quatre, cinq heures par mois.
Donc c'était absolument pas une fonction à temps plein publique. C'est d'ailleurs pas une fonction publique. Et quand j'ai décidé de prendre la parole, c'était après cinq semaines où on faisait que parler à ma place-
D'accord.
Et après une agression en réunion-
Ok.
Qui était ma limite.
Mais donc tu ne considères pas que le fait d'avoir accepté cette offre, d'avoir rempli cette mission de commissaire, c'est une prise de position, c'est une apparition dans la sphère publique.
Non, ça l'est pas du tout.
Pour toi, c'était vraiment derrière un bureau-
C'est clairement derrière la ministre. Par exemple, un commissaire du gouvernement ne prend pas la parole. S'il y avait une prise de parole, ça aurait été à la ministre.
C'est ça.
Et c'est aussi quelque chose que j'ai fait. Donc j'avais, comme je disais, j'avais créé mon association, j'avais déjà démissionné, quitté mon emploi à temps plein parce que je voulais créer ma propre entreprise et j'avais,
et j'avais aussi, enfin voilà, arrêté aussi mon association.
Parce que je me suis dit ok, c'est un engagement politique, donc c'est pas un mandat politique comme un député ou autre, mais c'est un engagement politique.
Et tant que j'étais le visage de mon association, je voulais absolument pas être vue comme faisant partie de tel ou tel parti.
Et donc c'est arrivé à un moment où j'avais déjà arrêté tout ça et où je voulais écrire mon livre.
Oui.
En gros, c'est là. Et c'est là qu'on m'a proposé ça. Et je me suis dit bah pourquoi pas, c'est quelques heures par mois, ça a l'air intéressant, tranquille.
Quelle innocence.
C'est ça, voilà. Et surtout que personnellement, j'avais une énorme charge mentale. À ce moment-là, c'était-
Ok.
C'était la crise Covid aussi, donc c'était très fatigant. J'avais géré l'association pendant huit ans. Il y avait aussi toute la question du transfert de nos activités qui étaient physiques en virtuel.
J'avais, enfin voilà, j'ai eu plusieurs choses qui se sont passées aussi dans ma vie personnelle qui faisaient que je me suis dit : Ok, là, j'ai envie de me poser
et d'enfin prendre le temps pour écrire quelque chose que je voulais toujours faire.
Et c'est là qu'on est venu me proposer ça. Et donc j'étais déjà à un niveau de charge mentale élevé et je pensais, voilà, je pensais naïvement, comme tu dis, que ça allait être quelque chose de léger, d'intéressant comme ça.
Pourquoi pas ? Et voilà, ça l'était pas.
Mais donc oui, vraiment une surprise à ce moment-là pour toi de voir que le fait d'accepter cette mission-
Mh.
Mais t'as mis au-devant de la scène alors que c'était vraiment pas le principe de base.
Non.
Et donc d'après toi, pourquoi est-ce que ça s'est passé comme ça ?
Ben, je pense qu'il y a eu un... En fait, en gros, je me suis beaucoup posé la question et j'ai parlé après ça à des personnes spécialisées en communication en disant : Tiens, qu'est-ce que tu penses ?
Des personnes dans le milieu politique, au niveau institutionnel. Tout le monde me dit : Écoute, personne n'aurait pu savoir cette vague de...
Personne n'aurait pu prévoir-
Mh.
Cette vague de violence. C'est-à-dire qu'on aurait pu prévoir un petit peu. Ok. Donc, j'aurais pu être plus préparée, ça, c'est clair.
Mais ce niveau-là, voilà, c'était pas prévu. Je pense que ça arrivait aussi à un momentum. Il y avait aussi le débat à la STIB sur la question des portes fonctionnelles.
C'est vrai, peu de temps avant, oui.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et beaucoup n'ont pas supporté la décision de justice qui était en faveur donc de la femme qui avait déposé plainte, qui avait été refusée à cause du fait qu'elle portait le foulard.
Et donc beaucoup avaient une frustration. Et donc je suis arrivée-
Un contexte politique plus global de-
Voilà, c'est ça.
Certains partis en particulier qui prônaient, qui s'opposaient très clairement à cette décision-là et qui voulaient faire pencher le-
Mh.
Le gouvernement d'un côté. Et donc ouais, et donc effectivement, ouais, le timing a sans doute joué.
Je pense, ouais. Je pense, ouais. Et puis voilà, il y a eu Twitter aussi. Twitter qui est clairement un vecteur, voilà, qui aide à la propagation de la haine sans trop de souci, je pense.
Voilà, j'ai eu des tweets que j'ai dénoncés au début naïvement en me disant : Ben quand même, c'est violent là, oh, il m'insulte.
Dénoncer, tu as cliqué sur le petit bouton report.
Oui, et puis c'était délit d'opinion. Enfin, il y avait des choses vraiment-
Ah oui, oui.
Enfin, 'fin, 'fin, il y en avait qui me traitaient, par exemple, pour prendre un mot, pute, terroriste.
Mh.
Et Twitter me répond ça, c'est juste une question d'opinion. Non, c'est pas une opinion, c'est une insulte. C'est une insulte grave qui a une conséquence sur la vie des gens.
C'est... Je veux dire, quand tu traites quelqu'un de ça, non, ça va pas. Mais c'était un délit d'opinion. Non, c'est pas un délit d'opinion.
Enfin voilà, donc c'était un-
Mh.
Et c'est pour ça que j'ai, voilà, le réseau, je n'y participe pas.
Oui oui. Parmi les autres valeurs que tu prends dans ton livre, il y a aussi, on va y arriver, la question de la patience et de l'empathie.
C'est particulièrement évident que ça fait partie de tes valeurs personnelles. Quand
tu parles des énervés sur Twitter, justement, dans une interview pour Le Soir en deux mille vingt et un, tu disais : Je peux comprendre que quand on ne baigne pas dans l'université, on a peur des personnes qui en sont issues.
Quand on s'enferme et qu'on les stigmatise, on va dans du fondamentalisme.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui t'est venu naturellement, ces valeurs de, voilà d'être, même avec des haineux comme ça sur Twitter, d'essayer de se mettre à leur place,
d'essayer de comprendre leur position, comment est-ce que ça leur est arrivé, etc.
Je suis impressionné en fait, par ta réponse dans cette interview, de voir à quel point tu essayes de comprendre le point de vue de l'autre.
Est-ce que t'es quelqu'un à qui l'empathie est venue très naturellement ou bien est-ce que c'est quelque chose sur lequel tu as dû beaucoup travailler ?
Ben moi, j'ai une mère qui est très empathique.
Ok.
Et quand j'étais plus petite, je me rappelle que j'observais des conflits qu'elle pouvait avoir, voilà, comme ça peut arriver un peu à tout le monde.
Et elle avait toujours ce truc de ne jamais avoir de haine envers personne et de se dire : Oui, mais peut-être que ci, peut-être que ça.
Et moi, je me rappelle, à treize ans, je m'étais mise en colère contre une dame plus âgée parce que je trouvais qu'elle avait mal parlé à ma mère.
Et pourtant, ma mère, c'est quelqu'un qui se défend, donc c'est pas, voilà. Mais elle me disait toujours, ma mère : Écoute, si ton cœur se remplit de haine, à ce moment-là, ils ont gagné et tu dormiras mal et c'est à toi que tu fais mal.
Donc avoir son cœur rempli de haine, c'est à soi-même qu'on se fait mal. Et donc je me suis toujours dit ça, c'est-à-dire que je peux pas remplir mon cœur de haine, sinon ben ils auront gagné et je serai devenue finalement comme eux.
Quel est l'intérêt ? Et donc, je pense aussi que fondamentalement,
chacun a un parcours de vie. Et de ce que j'ai pu voir, 'fin comme j'ai la particularité de baigner dans des milieux dans lesquels il y a peu, pas forcément beaucoup de gens qui me ressemblent.
J'ai appris aussi à écouter des histoires de vie et à mieux comprendre pourquoi, ben certains ont la haine dès qu'ils voient quelqu'un comme moi.
Ce qui ne veut pas dire que c'est OK, c'est pas justi-- ça ne justifie pas d'ailleurs non plus, mais arriver à le comprendre, ben ça veut dire que je peux essayer de discuter et qu'on peut essayer d'améliorer les choses.
J'avais notamment un voisin super raciste, j'en parle d'ailleurs dans le livre aussi. Mes parents étaient impressionnés du fait que je me rappelais de cette histoire.
Voilà, j'avais seize ans. Il était venu m'agresser à la maison et on me demandait si je parlais français. Enfin, c'était assez horrible.
Enfin, il appelait la police pour un moindre truc. Et en gros, après, quand j'ai connu son histoire, je me dis : OK, ce type, en fait, il a jamais connu quelqu'un qui vient de la diversité.
Et la seule fois, il a reconnu, ben, ça s'était mal passé. Et donc c'est pas OK, mais voilà, ça sert à rien de diaboliser les autres.
Je pense que fondamentalement, l'être humain n'est pas mauvais, et qu'on peut toujours essayer de, voilà, de s'entendre et de s'écouter et d'accepter aussi qu'on puisse être en désaccord.
Ce qui n'est pas acceptable, c'est d'attaquer les autres personnellement, c'est de rendre leur vie un enfer. Ça, c'est pas, ça, c'est pas OK.
Par contre, qu'on puisse se dire ben, on est en désaccord et je passe mon temps avec des gens avec qui j'ai des désaccords.
Et je pense qu'on ne peut pas être en accord de toute façon avec quelqu'un à cent pour cent, ça n'existe pas. Et fondamentalement, au niveau des valeurs, je pense qu'on se rejoint tous.
Je veux dire, tout le monde va dire que l'amour, c'est essentiel. Tout le monde va dire que le respect, c'est important.
Mais comment on décline le respect ? Par exemple, une fois, j'étais intervenue dans un conflit entre collègues où l'un, enfin, il ne supportait pas.
C'était horrible, c'était violent et on était la même équipe. Et à un moment donné, quand j'ai commencé à parler à l'un et à l'autre, l'un me dit : Oui, écoute, elle est infernale.
Quand elle vient, elle est super impolie, elle me manque de respect, elle me dit même pas bonjour. Et quand je parle à ma collègue, elle me dit : Ben en fait, ce gars, il est vraiment mal poli.
Je suis concentrée, il vient, il me déconcentre juste pour me dire bonjour. Et ils trouvaient tous les deux que l'autre leur manquait de respect.
Mais sur le fond, on est d'accord de dire que le respect, c'est important. C'est comment on décline que ça se passe.
Et c'est là-dessus où, par exemple, je me suis formée en programmation neurolinguistique pour essayer de mieux comprendre les autres et me comprendre moi-même, parce qu'on est aussi nous-mêmes pleins de contradictions.
C'est aussi accepter ses propres imperfections et ses propres contradictions.
Et c'est aussi pour ça que je m'intéresse beaucoup à des sujets de psychologie, que je lis beaucoup là-dessus, parce que ça me permet de mieux comprendre comment l'être humain marche.
Mais c'est-- je continue à dire que c'est vraiment très impressionnant, cette patience, cette capacité à entendre des propos super désagréables comme ceux de ton voisin, de te mettre à sa place, essayer de comprendre son point de vue.
Comment est-ce que tu fais l'équilibre entre, voilà, cette démarche de patience, d'empathie, de compréhension du point de vue d'autrui et ton propre bien-être ?
Comment est-ce que tu fais pour que ça ne te fatigue pas, ça ne te vide pas les batteries d'entendre des horreurs ?
C'est une bonne question. C'est vrai que ça m'épuise. C'est très fatigant, la patience.
Oui, parce que quand on lit ton livre, on a l'impression que c'est très : Ah voilà, tout le monde s'est pas fait. Oui, la patience, l'empathie.
Voilà, il suffit de faire ça. Mais en fait, concrètement, on sait que c'est épuisant.
C'est ultra-épuisant. La patience, c'est très épuisant. Se mettre à la place de l'autre aussi, c'est très épuisant. Je pense que c'est parce que j'essaie toujours de me rappeler c'est quoi mon why, pourquoi je fais les choses.
Et je me dis finalement que je ne suis pas tellement importante, que d'ailleurs quand on m'attaque, ce n'est pas moi qu'on attaque personnellement.
Alors, je sais que c'est facile à dire, mais ce n'est pas pour autant que je n'étais pas blessée, que je n'ai pas pris les choses personnellement.
Mais essayer de se dégager de ça en disant : Ce n'est pas moi personnellement, c'est ce que je dégage, c'est l'image que je véhicule chez l'autre qui donne ça.
Et aussi de se dire pourquoi je fais les choses, c'est-à-dire que moi, mon intérêt, c'est qu'on puisse vivre mieux ensemble.
Je sais que ça fait un peu Miss Belgique, Miss Monde de dire ça, mais c'est vraiment un intérêt profond que j'ai. Je veux dire, on est quand même dans un monde où on a des guerres un peu partout,
et de se dire, la guerre ici,
même si ma famille, ma génération n'était pas là à ce moment-là, la guerre en Europe, elle date d'il y a pas si longtemps.
Et quand je vois des choses qui se passent, ça m'inquiète et je me dis toujours pourquoi je fais les choses. Et je me dis : Je fais ce que je peux, je vais pas changer toute la société, mais je fais ce que je peux à mon échelle.
Et pouvoir me dire, voilà, si demain je meurs, je peux me dire que j'ai fait ce que je pouvais pour améliorer les choses à mon échelle.
Et pour moi, enfin voilà, le pourquoi tu fais les choses, il est très important et c'est quelque chose qui m'a toujours
aussi animée dans toutes les démarches sociales que j'ai pu faire, où j'essayais toujours de ne pas tomber dans l'ego, de dire : C'est mon projet.
C'est pour ça d'ailleurs que mon projet à un moment donné, Teen, je l'ai quitté quand ça a commencé à grandir et que ça a commencé à bien marcher, en me disant : Ça peut jamais tourner autour de ma personne.
Et donc voilà, de sortir un peu de cet ego. J'essayais beaucoup de travailler sur l'ego. C'est pour ça aussi que j'ai eu beaucoup de problèmes, de mal à
m'identifier comme personnalité publique, parce qu'on m'a identifiée comme personnalité publique.
Et moi, je veux pas qu'on parle de moi personnellement, je veux qu'on parle de mes projets. C'est ça qui compte, c'est ce que je fais, pas qui je suis.
Ok. Et aujourd'hui, tu en es où par rapport à ça ? Parce que tu es ici en tant qu'Ihsane Haouach. C'est toi que j'ai invitée, c'est toi qui publies un livre.
C'est ça. Mais c'est là où je me dis : OK, je sais que-- et je sais que le storytelling est important. Je sais que c'est toujours une question personnelle.
Et donc, je me dis : OK, si ce statut de personnalité publique peut m'aider à faire passer des messages qui me tiennent à cœur, OK, so be it.
Mais j'essaie toujours de veiller à ne pas sombrer dans l'ego, parce que sinon, je me serais perdue.
Ok. Donc, tu utilises cette humilité à laquelle tu tiens très fort pour finalement t'extraire de l'équation quand tu regardes ces insultes, quand tu regardes ces expériences négatives, tu te dis : Bon, finalement,
je n'ai pas vraiment d'importance dans tout ça.
Ce n'est pas vraiment après moi qu'ils en ont.
C'est ça.
Et tu te retires du...
Tu te retires de l'équation.
Et ce qu'il y a aussi, c'est que ce qui me conforte dans l'idée, c'est, comme je te disais, le fait que dans la vraie vie, ce n'est pas comme ça.
Donc, j'ai croisé entre-temps des personnes qui m'avaient attaquée sur les réseaux.
Ok. Tu es allée boire un café avec eux ?
Il y a des personnes avec qui j'ai été déjeuner, mais ça, ce sont des personnes qui m'ont pas attaquée personnellement, qui ont attaqué plus la fonction-
Ok.
Qui ont fait ces distinctions, et c'est moi-même qui les ai contactées en disant : J'aimerais bien qu'on ait un débat de fond parce que le débat m'intéresse
et qu'on-- j'ai-- de prime abord, je disais : On va se quitter très certainement en désaccord, il faut accepter ça.
Est-ce que tu l'as fait avec des personnalités du mouvement réformateur ? Avec des-- Est-ce que tu as invité Georges-Louis Bouchez à aller prendre un café ?
J'ai discuté avec des gens du mouvement réformateur-
Ok.
Mais comme je disais, ceux qui m'ont attaquée personnellement et ceux qui représentent un système qui pour moi est un vrai danger pour la société, non.
Ok. Oui, donc l'extrême droite quoi. Tu ne peux pas débattre avec l'extrême droite.
Disons que je crois aux cordons sanitaires.
C'est ça, oui. Oui. Ce podcast est aligné sur ces valeurs-là aussi, donc c'est parfait. Mais non, je t'ai interrompue, excuse-moi.
Donc tu parlais du fait que tu es allée à la rencontre de-
Et donc il y a des personnes à qui j'ai vraiment été à la rencontre, des personnes aussi qui m'avaient soutenue sur les réseaux et je disais-- qui me proposaient de se voir.
Et donc du coup, voilà, j'ai étalé du mois de septembre au mois de décembre, pendant que j'écrivais mon livre, quelques déjeuners.
Et donc ça me permettait aussi de sortir un peu de ma bulle et ça m'alimentait aussi, toutes ces discussions.
Et il y a des personnes, voilà, qui m'avaient attaquée personnellement, avec qui j'avais pas-- j'allais pas aller spontanément leur proposer d'aller boire un café,
que j'ai croisées à des événements et qui venaient me parler comme si de rien n'était.
C'est un peu gonflé, hein, oui.
Et-- Mais c'est-- Le problème, 'fin, c'est des personnalités politiques. Et pour ces personnalités-là, c'est le jeu.
Oui.
Et du coup, j'avais du mal.
Je les regardais. Oui, je suis contente de vous rencontrer parce que voilà, on a eu des discussions. Je dis : Mais déjà, on n'a pas eu de discussion, vous m'avez attaquée.
Et donc j'étais assez... Là sur le coup, je me sentais plus légère du fait d'avoir pu dire ce que je pensais à ces personnes-là, tout le moment, ok, hors caméra, hors média, parce que c'est pas le but que tout doive être un show.
Et que j'ai pu avoir des discussions que j'espère en tout cas sincères avec ces personnes-là, en leur expliquant en quoi
leurs propos m'avaient blessée et que ce n'était pas acceptable et qu'elles ne devaient pas recommencer ça avec quelqu'un d'autre.
Que maintenant, elles peuvent plus dire : Je ne savais pas, et recommencer ça avec quelqu'un d'autre.
Tu t'es sentie entendue, écoutée ou moyennement ?
Je sais pas quelles sont les intentions des gens. Je peux pas les juger, je peux juste juger des dires. Et qu'en général, les gens se sont excusés et qui
restaient sans voix quand je citais des faits précis que ces personnes-là avaient dit.
Et donc voilà, en tout cas, ce que je sais, c'est que j'ai eu des excuses.
C'est déjà ça.
Voilà, il y en a eu qui m'ont fait des câlins, je m'étais un peu étonnée, je savais pas trop quoi faire, j'avoue.
Ok. Câlins consentis ou un peu forcés ?
C'était un câlin. Donc voilà, je sais pas. 'Fin, je suis là : Ok, c'est... 'Fin, j'étais un peu déconcertée, j'avoue, je comprenais pas trop le truc.
Je me dis : Attends, il y a un mois, t'es en train de m'attaquer et de dire que je suis le diable, etc. Et qu'elle a dit ça, elle a dit ça.
Et puis là, un gros hug et je suis désolée. Voilà, encore un peu, il y aurait des larmes, mais je veux dire, je sais pas.
T'as dit, ou des experts en communication t'ont signalé à ce moment-là que c'était en fait une super opportunité, que tu devais rebondir là-dessus, en profiter pour exprimer un message.
Et tu as choisi de ne pas le faire. Pourquoi ?
Parce que comme je-- pour moi, il est toujours important d'être ancrée. Et là, j'étais plus ancrée. J'étais déstabilisée.
Mh.
Et euh...
T'as besoin de te reposer.
J'avais besoin de prendre du temps pour moi. J'avais besoin et je voulais-- Et ce qui me dérangeait, c'est que je sentais que j'étais instrumentalisée de tous les côtés.
Mh. De tous les côtés, c'est-à-dire ?
De tous les côtés. C'est-à-dire que même ceux qui me voulaient en théorie du bien
pouvaient me faire du mal sans s'en rendre compte,
sans me demander mon avis dans certaines publications par exemple, qui allaient m'exposer sur un réseau sur lequel j'étais pas exposée et que ça allait me ramasser une meute de nouveaux haters.
Ok.
Et
le fait que j'étais complètement dépossédée de mon visage, de mon nom, de-- qu'on parlait plus de tout ce que j'ai pu faire en quatorze ans d'expérience, qu'on parlait plus que de ça,
plus que de ce que j'ai pu dire ou pas dire dans des interviews ou des versions brouillon d'interview ou quoi.
Je me suis dit : Mais c'est pas possible. Je dois reprendre position-- possession de ma vie.
Donc on revient sur le fait que t'as un caractère plutôt humble, plutôt discret et que tu acceptais une mission en partant du principe que c'était pas sous les projecteurs, c'était pas dans la vie publique.
Et puis à ce moment-là, en fait, tu voulais revenir à une position plus humble, plus discrète, loin des projecteurs.
Voilà.
Donc c'était pas ton but de...
C'est ça. Pour moi, le fait de s'exposer publiquement, c'est pour faire passer un message. Par exemple, là, mon livre. Sinon, j'ai pas d'intérêt.
Et j'ai même hésité à le publier en anonyme.
Ce livre-ci ? Ok.
Oui, mais après, c'était trop personnel, donc 'fin, c'était quand même des histoires personnelles et ça aurait pas marché.
Mh.
Voilà.
Oui. Oui, et tu acceptes de faire des interviews. Donc, tu me disais qu'aujourd'hui, je suis une des premières personnes à lire le livre et je suis une des premières interviews que tu fais dans ce cadre-là.
Mais tu vas en faire d'autres, tu imagines. Tu vas le promouvoir activement, ce livre ?
Oui, je vais essayer de le promouvoir, c'est sûr. Et je vais essayer de travailler dessus aussi. 'Fin, j'ai déjà des entreprises qui me contactent pour faire des ateliers, pour faire des keynotes, des conférences dans les entreprises.
Et donc c'est là que je vois de nouveau, bah, les entreprises privées vont faire appel à moi pour mon expertise et ce que j'ai à apporter.
Voilà, je dis pas qu'on me juge pas, mais en me jugeant un peu moins que dans la sphère politique. Et oui, c'est clair.
Après, je vais pas aller dans tous les médias. J'ai pas envie d'être dans des débats polémiques. 'Fin, ça ne sert à rien.
Tu vas pas aller le dimanche sur RTL pour promouvoir ton livre ?
Écoute, j'ai déjà été sur ce genre de débats et honnêtement, je me sens pas à l'aise. Je sors de là et j'ai l'impression que j'ai été nulle, que c'était agressif dans tous les sens et que j'ai pas envie de participer à ce genre de débats.
C'est pas du contenu, c'est... 'Fin voilà, je me sens pas à l'aise. Je pense qu'il y a des gens qui peuvent le faire très bien, mais moi, c'est vrai que ça correspond pas à mon profil.
On m'a proposé d'ailleurs d'être chroniqueuse dans certains médias. Je suis pas une débatteuse. Voilà, je peux faire de temps en temps des chroniques, oui, mais c'est pas...
'Fin, ça m'intéresse pas d'aller chaque semaine sur un média...
Donner ton avis sur des trucs qui concernent pas-
J'ai un avis sur tout, mais je veux dire, j'ai pas... J'aime bien construire les choses. J'aime bien avoir une vraie expertise avant de dire quelque chose.
Et est-ce que tu t'attends-- est-ce qu'avec la sortie de ce livre, avec un retour, voilà, un petit peu sous les projecteurs en petite échelle.
Est-ce que tu t'attends à de nouveau peut-être recevoir, voilà, des commentaires désagréables, peut-être un positionnement de politicien, ou est-ce que tu penses que ça va rester discret ?
Écoute-
Est-ce que tu vas rester en paix ou pas ?
Je crois que je serai jamais en paix.
Ok. Plus jamais ou tu l'as-- Tu l'étais par le passé ou tu l'as jamais-
Non, je crois que je l'ai jamais vraiment été par le passé.
Ok.
J'ai très vite été-- enfin, j'étais dans une école, voilà, une bonne école, mais où il y avait peu de personnes d'origine étrangère.
Donc je me-- voilà, j'ai connu malheureusement les agressions depuis toujours. Les agressions en tout cas par rapport à mes identités.
Et donc c'est pas ça, mais je pense que la paix, on la trouve soi-même dans son-- pour moi, le petit noyau familial est très important.
On trouve la paix là, je la trouve aussi, voilà, je-- quand je joue du piano, ou que je lis un livre en fait, ou que je fais du sport, ou que je vais dans la nature, c'est...
La paix, on la trouve là. Mais dans la société, je crois que-- je sais pas si quelqu'un est vraiment en paix dans la société, encore plus si on est exposé.
Mais donc là, ouais, j'ai fait mon deuil par rapport à ça. Je pense qu'il y aura des réactions, oui, mais je pense que de toute façon, ceux qui ont décidé de me détester, ben ils continueront à me détester.
Et ceux qui décident de me soutenir, ben je pense qu'ils vont continuer à me soutenir. Et puis il y a juste ce milieu que j'espère, voilà, pouvoir
échanger avec eux, avoir un dialogue constructif, pas forcément pour influencer, mais au moins pour me faire entendre.
Pour revenir à ton livre, à un moment donné, tu donnes un exemple qui m'a particulièrement frappé.
C'était dans le cadre d'un événement qui était justement consacré, au sein de la boîte pour laquelle tu travaillais, qui était consacré à la diversité.
Et donc il était question des plats que chacun avait apportés. Et toi, tu avais apporté, je crois, des frites.
Spaghetti bolognaise.
Spaghetti bolo. Et tu-
J'avais hésité avec une moule-frites.
Voilà, c'est ça. Exactement. Et la collègue avec laquelle tu discutais était particulièrement surprise de voir que tu n'avais pas amené du couscous.
Ouais.
Puis toi, tu as plaisanté en disant voilà, t'as visité avec les frites, voilà. Et elle t'a répondu un truc.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle t'a répondu ?
Elle m'a dit : « Un jour, tu y arriveras ».
Ok.
Comme si j'étais dans un déni de mon identité.
C'est ça.
Et je disais mais... Je sais très bien qui je suis, je suis alignée avec moi-même, mais je suis fière de ce que je suis.
Je suis fière d'avoir mon identité,
d'être belge, d'être d'origine marocaine, d'être musulmane, d'être une femme, d'être encore en dessous de quarante ans, ce qui me permet de faire partie de certains programmes, d'être à la fois dans le social, dans le public, dans le privé.
J'adore ce que je fais et donc je cache pas mes identités. C'est juste que voilà, les plats que j'aime, j'ai jamais fait encore maintenant, j'ai jamais fait de couscous de ma vie.
Le couscous de ma mère est trop bon. J'essaye même pas. J'essaye même pas, je suis hors compète. Donc voilà. Et j'adore faire des spaghettis bolognaise.
Je l'ai fait cuire pendant deux heures et demie, la vraie recette italienne. Et donc j'avais fait ça et j'étais fière de moi et c'était : « Ah ben non ».
Il y en avait un qui m'avait dit : « Moi, j'avais promis à ma femme que j'allais ramener du couscous. C'est quoi ça ? T'es pas italienne quand même ».
Et l'autre qui, complètement, voilà, côté très maternaliste, j'ai souvent eu ça. « Un jour, tu y arriveras. Un jour, tu t'accepteras comme t'es ».
Mais je m'accepte déjà. Donc... Et donc voilà, c'est là le côté où il y a un côté quelquefois bienveillant qui est très déplacé, où on n'écoute pas les gens.
Il y a par exemple un exemple que Ilham Kadri aussi dit dans mon livre, elle dit voilà, quand les femmes reviennent de maternité, c'est qu'on suppose pour nous.
Donc par exemple, elle raconte qu'on a supposé pour elle quand elle revenait de congé maternité : « Ah ben t'inquiète pas, tu vas pas beaucoup voyager ».
Mais qui a dit que je voulais pas voyager ? Qui a dit ça ? Et donc moi aussi mon retour de maternité, il était assez violent parce que j'avais l'impression d'être bonne nulle part, de culpabiliser par-ci, par-là.
Enfin voilà. Et donc quelquefois, on suppose pour la vie des gens, mais il faut leur poser la question. Et les gens sont suffisamment aptes à répondre pour eux-mêmes.
Donc ce maternalisme-là, est-ce que tu l'inscris en particulier dans un rapport des Blancs face à la diversité ?
Ce qu'on appelle plus généralement, oui, l'espèce de colonialisme, une espèce de...
Je sais pas si cet exemple-là est particulièrement pertinent par rapport à ce qu'on appelle le féminisme blanc, mais est-ce que ce maternalisme-là,
il est pas en fait assez omniprésent dans la façon dont, oui, les personnes issues de la diversité, en particulier donc ici les personnes qui portent le foulard, est-ce que c'est pas omniprésent dans...
Ben moi, j'ai eu du temps à parler de moi en tant que féministe et d'avoir vraiment des actions féministes labellisées comme ça parce que je me reconnaissais pas dans le féminisme mainstream.
C'est ça.
Ok. Et il y avait ce côté toujours ben les féministes, c'est comme on allait en Algérie, les Français allaient en Algérie en disant aux femmes : « Dévoilez-vous, on va vous libérer ».
Donc il y avait ce côté-là où moi, finalement, j'ai découvert le sexisme la première fois que j'ai été victime de vraiment de sexisme quand j'ai pas eu la promotion alors qu'un collègue masculin a eu une promotion
plus que moi alors que j'avais une meilleure évaluation.
Ok. C'est là que j'ai fait : « Quoi ? Ça aussi, je dois rajouter ça ? J'en ai pas assez avec les racines, il faut me rajouter ça ».
Et que là, j'ai commencé, ben du coup en entreprise, j'ai commencé à relancer un réseau qui était mort en entreprise, de femmes en entreprise.
Et j'ai commencé à écouter plein de témoignages de femmes racisées et non racisées, surtout non racisées, qui racontaient leur histoire.
Et je me disais ah ouais, mais c'est quand même encore aujourd'hui assez violent.
Et donc c'est pour ça que j'ai créé ma structure en fait à ce moment-là de féminisme intersectionnel en me disant ben finalement, on va parler pour nous-mêmes et on va aussi s'approprier ce mot, le féminisme, c'est aussi pour nous.
Qu'importe si pour certaines, le foulard, c'est antiféministe, c'est leur opinion.
Mh.
C'est leur opinion, je la respecte, mais qu'elles ne m'imposent rien et moi, je leur imposerai rien. C'est aussi simple que ça.
Ouais.
Et donc c'est là-dessus. Alors maintenant, je suis contente parce qu'on parle beaucoup de féminisme intersectionnel. Il y a quelques années, non.
Mais c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que j'ai toujours eu cette logique
de penser pourquoi je fais les choses. Et donc après, j'ai arrêté cette association parce que finalement ben d'autres le faisaient en étant des plus grosses structures qui avaient déjà beaucoup de subventions, ont commencé à s'approprier.
Et donc pour moi, c'était il y a pas de souci, prenez ça, il y a tellement de choses à faire. Mais voilà, le féminisme intersectionnel, c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez récent.
C'est ça. Oui, d'ailleurs, tu ouvres en fait ton livre avec une remarque de ce style-là où tu dis : « Oui, les féministes ont un peu mauvaise réputation, un peu de merdeuse », mais en fait, voilà.
Donc ça vient de là en fait.
Ouais.
Ça vient du fait que historiquement, et j'ai l'impression que c'est, tu peux me contredire si je dis une bêtise, mais j'ai l'impression que c'est souvent le cas quand j'entends des femmes musulmanes se prononcer.
Ce rapport aux féministes a souvent été entaché par, oui donc, ce féminisme blanc.
Ouais.
Plutôt au féminisme donc qui se présente comme étant universaliste, qui vient voilà avec une incompréhension.
Et qui vient avec un discours assez maternaliste dire aux femmes qui portent le foulard
Voilà.
ce qu'il doit faire.
En gros, pour moi le féminisme, le féminisme doit aussi, et ça je le mets dans mon livre, le féminisme doit aussi être inclusif.
Mh.
Inclusif à la fois des personnes dites de la diversité, mais également auprès des hommes. Donc je suis pour le fait d'avoir des hommes féministes avec nous parce que sinon de toute façon, on n'y arrivera pas.
Et que pour moi le féminisme, c'est plus une question d'être même d'être humaniste, c'est-à-dire, c'est d'avoir cette vision de l'équité, de penser à l'équité pour tout le monde.
Et c'est aussi simple que ça. Et donc à partir du moment où tu viens penser à la place de quelqu'un, tu peux pas être féministe, tu peux pas être pour l'équité parce que tu penses à sa place.
Il faut poser la question et respecter si quelqu'un dit c'est mon choix, tu respectes.
Mh.
Ça sert à rien de commencer à dire oui, mais est-ce que c'est vraiment ton choix ? Et ton frère là-dedans, et ton père, et ton mari, et ton oncle, je sais pas quoi.
C'est-- finalement, il faut aussi se dire qu'on est tous et tous influencés par les autres. On est tous et tous influencés par la société.
Et donc évidemment qu'on a des influences dans nos vies, mais si je te dis que c'est mon choix, ben estime que j'ai l'intelligence suffisante pour penser à moi-même.
Si on pense que malgré le fait que j'ai dit c'est mon choix, on continue à m'imposer, ça veut dire qu'on me pense pas suffisamment intelligente pour penser pour moi-même.
Et là-dessus, on peut pas être féministe.
Ouais.
On peut pas non plus être féministe en empêchant l'accès à l'éducation et l'accès à l'emploi, ce qui sont des vecteurs d'émancipation fondamentaux, à des femmes.
On peut pas être féministe en leur empêchant d'étudier et de travailler.
C'est intéressant parce que justement cette logique de on peut pas être féministe si on s'exprime à la place des autres femmes, c'est justement la logique que certaines
femmes féministes utilisent pour justifier que justement les hommes peuvent du coup pas être féministes puisqu'ils sont pas en place pour
Mh.
ils n'ont pas la perspective, ils n'ont pas la place pour défendre le droit des femmes puisque finalement défendre les droits des femmes quand on est un homme, c'est parler à la place des femmes.
Non. Pas si les femmes gardent le contrôle du mouvement
Mh.
et restent le visage. On a besoin de soutien.
Ouais.
Ce qu'on ne veut pas, enfin ce qu'on ne veut pas, ce que je ne veux pas en tout cas, je suis la porte-parole de personne.
Ce que je ne voudrais pas, c'est qu'on prenne notre place. Ça, c'est le danger des hommes qui malgré eux peuvent être dominants.
Mh.
Et prendre la place. Ok, je vais donner un exemple, j'avais organisé un atelier en non-mixité et ben des jeunes que je connais, des jeunes super sympas, donc c'est même pas des gars, on va dire, c'est des sexistes ou quoi,
sont passés par là en se disant : « Ah, c'est un atelier, est-ce qu'on peut participer ?
» Les accompagnatrices disent ok. Moi, je reçois la photo de cet atelier et je dis à ce moment-là à mes bénévoles : « Qu'est-ce que font ces deux garçons-là ?
S'il te plaît, tu leur demandes de quitter. » Elle me dit : « Oui, ça se fait pas et tout. » Je dis non, tu leur demandes de quitter parce que c'est un atelier en non-mixité choisi.
Donc il faut pouvoir respecter ça. Et je lui dis ce qui va se passer, c'est qu'ils vont prendre la parole, et dominer sans même se rendre compte.
Ils vont être les premiers à prendre la parole de manière stéréotypée. C'est sûrement ça qui se passe. Et c'est exactement ça qui s'est passé.
C'est-à-dire le fait qu'il y avait deux garçons. Il y avait douze femmes. Les garçons ont spontanément pris la parole et les femmes se sont spontanément mises en retrait.
Et donc c'est pour ça que des ateliers en non-mixité sont importants pour pouvoir justement libérer la parole. Maintenant, il y a des ateliers en non-mixité et des ateliers en mixité.
Il y a des conférences, il y a des expositions photos, toutes des choses qu'on peut utiliser pour être dans une société plus inclusive.
Mais il faut d'abord pouvoir s'éduquer. Et pour s'éduquer, il faut pouvoir avoir cet espace de liberté, il faut avoir cet espace.
Et donc pour moi, les hommes doivent contribuer. C'est même pas de volonté, c'est un,
c'est un devoir citoyen que de vouloir l'équité pour tout le monde, tout comme les personnes non racisées doivent s'impliquer pour les personnes racisées.
Parce qu'il faut aussi se dire qu'on est fatigué d'être tout le temps nous en train de lutter. On aimerait bien avoir un peu d'aide.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose qu'on m'a aussi dit : « Oui, mais voilà, j'ai pas envie de parler à ta place. » Mais ne parle pas à ma place, aide-moi.
Ok, aide-moi, demande-moi ce que je veux et t'inquiète pas, t'auras plein de choses à faire.
Personnellement, donc je suis toujours, je me sens effectivement toujours très ignorant quand je m'exprime au sujet des questions de, par exemple, de racisme, par exemple d'islamophobie ou ces questions-là.
Et donc j'ai plutôt tendance à me dire bon ben, je vais juste me taire et éventuellement inviter les personnes concernées pour en parler.
Et toi, tu me dis, et c'est effectivement des choses que je peux entendre de personnes noires, personnes racisées qui vont me dire que ça les fatigue en fait de devoir s'exprimer là-dessus tout le temps.
Ouais.
Mais du coup, c'est très compliqué parce que moi, j'ai pas envie de parler à leur place.
Mais c'est compliqué, mais tu sais, il y a aussi... C'est pour ça que moi, je crois beaucoup au pouvoir de l'art et de la culture.
Ok.
Pour faire changer les choses. C'est que quelquefois, en parler frontalement, c'est pas ce qu'il y a de plus. Par exemple, moi, j'avais eu plein de débats avec des étudiants avec qui j'étudiais, et on s'était jamais compris.
On avait eu deux heures de débat. Et quand j'ai coécrit une pièce de théâtre et que j'ai joué sur scène
mon vécu, ben en trois, quatre minutes de pièce, c'est une pièce qui s'appelait Fruits étranges, de fruits étrangers créée par Ras El Hanout.
Et donc j'avais écrit ça, ils étaient venus et c'était : « Ah ouais, mais maintenant, je te comprends. » Donc en trois minutes de théâtre, ça a fait appel à l'empathie bien plus que les débats.
Et donc je pense que le fait aussi de marginaliser la présence des femmes, des personnes racisées, des personnes qui d'apparence sont différentes, que ça soit en handicap ou autre, fait déjà une différence.
Par exemple, dans mon livre, j'amène aussi l'exemple d'un homme qui est atteint de Parkinson et qui donne des formations.
J'ai assisté à une de ses formations. Et c'est très particulier parce qu'au début, on le voit parler comme ça et on est intimidé.
Et puis on n'a pas envie de le regarder bizarrement. Alors on essaie de faire attention et donc on est dans le contrôle de nos émotions et de notre regard parce qu'on veut pas qu'il sente qu'on le regarde différemment.
Au début, c'est difficile, mais après, on prend l'habitude. Et donc si je vois plus de personnes qui sont atteintes de Parkinson dans la vie de tous les jours,
je vais démystifier aussi leur handicap et je vais avoir plus facile à me dire : « Tiens, peut-être que je peux travailler avec ».
Tu vois ? Et donc je pense que faire changer les choses, c'est pas uniquement venir et faire un débat et écrire un livre ou voilà, c'est aussi vivre les choses et parler des projets.
Et donc si tu veux agir pour les femmes, par exemple les femmes racisées, ben invite-les dans ton podcast et parle d'autres choses que de féminisme et de racisme.
Est-ce qu'on a parlé d'autres choses que de féminisme et de racisme aujourd'hui ?
Pas suffisamment.
Ok. Tu veux parler de quoi ?
Mais tu as fait un effort, donc c'est bien.
Non, mais... il reste encore un peu de temps. Tu trouves qu'on n'a pas assez évoqué d'autres sujets dans cet entretien ?
Écoute, c'est assez particulier parce qu'aussi, tu as repris mon livre
Bah oui, c'est ça
...qui parle d'ouverture, mais dans mon livre, je vais justement beaucoup plus loin que l'apparence. Je parle beaucoup des profils.
Je parle justement de la diversité de profils, la diversité de pensées.
Ok.
Comment prendre des décisions aussi en incluant tout le monde ? Toutes les pensées, c'est pas qu'une question d'apparence.
Mmm, oui. Là, on peut-- C'est très méta ce qu'on va faire, mais j'ai effectivement, moi, vraiment une préférence de parler de personnes en fait.
Donc c'est pour ça qu'on a parlé aussi beaucoup de ton histoire, de tes parcours et de ce que tu fais aussi dans ton livre.
Tu parles de toi et de la façon dont t'es perçue, etc. Donc c'est effectivement une préférence que j'ai moi. Et donc, je sais pas, tu aurais préféré qu'on parle moins de toi ?
Ben, je te dis, c'est particulier parce qu'ici, tu m'invites pour parler, donc il y avait évidemment l'affaire Haouach.
Et puis, comme on avait dit, on ne va pas parler que de ça. Je peux aussi regarder le futur et aussi parler de mon livre qui reprend un modèle, qui reprend un modèle de société.
Donc en soi, c'est un modèle d'ouverture et d'inclusivité. Donc c'est un peu logique de parler de ça. Maintenant, par exemple, je sais pas, ce qui est intéressant, c'est de parler de la culture du débat.
Comment est-ce qu'on peut débattre, accepter de rester en désaccord
? C'est de parler de comment est-ce qu'on peut prendre une décision en collectif en s'assurant que tout le monde autour de la table est OK et qu'on a entendu toutes les idées de tout le monde.
Ok. Effectivement, moi, j'ai tendance à vouloir vraiment être très, oui, très concret
Ouais
...et très connecté à la personne que j'ai en face de moi. Donc, on peut parler de la culture du débat, mais à travers, ben on l'a un peu fait en fait quelque part, voilà.
Mais toujours à travers des expériences personnelles, des voilà donc-- Mais qui vont être du coup, de par le profil que tu représentes.
Oui, tout à fait.
Les expériences qui sont les tiennes
Mmm-hmm
...et qui vont donc, c'est triste à dire, mais inévitablement être impactées par les questions de racisme et de sexisme que tu abordes, que tu as traversées, voilà, et que tu évoques dans ton livre.
Donc c'est très compliqué en fait hein, de complètement se déconnecter et de pas parler de ça avec toi.
Non, c'est ça. Oui, mais moi, je te dis pas de pas faire ça avec moi parce que moi, j'ai un parcours en fait qui fait que je suis revenue à ces questions-là, même si j'ai souvent essayé d'en sortir.
Tu vois ? Ça me fait un peu penser à la phrase dans Le Deux Parrains, dans Le Parrain, le Godfather, quand il dit : « À chaque fois, j'essaie d'en sortir et ils me...
They bring me back in ». Tu vois, c'est à chaque fois ça quoi. Tu vas essayer d'en sortir et boum, on revient à ça.
Bonne référence, je ne m'attendais pas à ça.
Tu vois. Et donc il y a ça. Maintenant, ce que je dis, c'est que par exemple, tu peux inviter, par exemple, une femme noire qui va te parler, de par exemple, je sais pas, du métavers.
Ok ? Et même pas lui parler de sa couleur de peau. Tu vois, tu l'appelles, tu peux appeler quelqu'un pour parler d'énergie qui est d'origines diverses ou voilà. Donc
c'est juste ça. Et c'est ça que moi, j'ai reproché justement aux médias télé. C'est qu'on m'appelait et que ben jamais on me demandait-- À ce moment-là, je pouvais en quelque sorte encore donner des avis sur la transition énergétique.
Maintenant, je fais partie du conseil d'administration du régulateur. Donc en énergie, je veux jamais m'exprimer parce que c'est la position du régulateur et que je ne représente pas le régulateur bruxellois pour l'énergie.
Donc c'est ça. Mais je veux dire, à ce moment-là, je pouvais parler d'énergie parce que j'avais quitté mon emploi, mais on ne m'appelait pas pour ça.
Ok ? Et pourtant, l'énergie, ça a toujours été central. Et donc voilà, c'est juste ça. Je me dis : finalement, on nous réduit aussi souvent à ça.
Et le problème aussi, et c'est là où tu n'as pas tort, c'est que nous-mêmes, on peut nous-mêmes nous réduire à ça parce qu'on est dans la lutte.
On est dans le : tu te soumets ou tu te bats. Ok ? Tu acceptes que ça se passe comme ça ou bien tu te bats pour changer les choses.
Et donc du coup, ben nous-mêmes, en quelque sorte, nos choix de vie vont être conditionnés par les épreuves qu'on peut avoir.
Mmm. Ok, oui, mais-- et en même temps, pendant que tu en parlais, je repensais au fait qu'effectivement, quand je pense aux voilà, aux septante intervenants, plus de septante intervenants que j'ai reçus dans ce podcast,
effectivement, je pense qu'il y a peut-être
une femme racisée qui était là pour parler d'autre chose que d'antiracisme, de racisme et de...
Oui. Et c'est pas un choix actif de ma part.
Ouais.
C'est aussi le fait que le... voilà, notre société est structurée d'une façon qui fait que tu-- C'est intéressant parce que tu parlais toi-même d'humilité tout à l'heure.
Mmm-hmm.
Je pense qu'effectivement, beaucoup, enfin, corrige-moi si je dis une bêtise, mais j'ai l'impression que beaucoup de femmes racisées vont avoir tendance à rester en retrait et à laisser...
...enfin, c'est pas leur choix uniquement, mais de cette humilité et de ce retrait, finalement, la parole publique va être monopolisée par des hommes blancs, par des femmes blanches.
Et donc c'est beaucoup plus compliqué quand je fais un sujet sur, je ne sais pas moi, sur l'intelligence artificielle, par exemple...
Mmm-hmm.
Ben en fait, même si c'était ma démarche, je pense que ce serait très compliqué de trouver un ou une experte...
Ouais.
...racisée pour parler de ça.
C'est ça. C'est pour ça que moi, je suis jamais pour le cinquante cinquante parce qu'on n'y arrivera pas.
Par contre, c'est un peu comme là tout à l'heure quand on parlait de... dans la tech, pour avoir des femmes dans la tech, parce que ça remonte aussi à l'éducation, à l'école et au choix d'école.
Tu peux toi travailler à ton échelle maintenant pour faire un effort actif pour aller chercher des profils d'apparences différentes qui vont venir parler d'autre chose que de leur apparence.
Et... mais pour autant, tu vas pas en avoir cinquante pour cent par rapport à tes profils. Ça, il faut pas viser.
Tu peux juste toi, enfin, ce qui est ton devoir en quelque sorte, c'est de faire l'effort d'aller chercher à faire un effort sincère. Et puis ben,
par exemple, moi, c'est aussi pour ça que j'adore donner des formations en techniques de présentation et j'aime de plus en plus le faire, surtout auprès des femmes,
parce qu'il y a toujours... enfin, c'est quand même, j'en ai donné une cette semaine, mais
c'est impressionnant comment les hommes ont plus facile à s'exprimer publiquement.
Et c'est une très bonne chose. Je veux dire, on va pas reprocher aux hommes d'avoir une facilité à s'exprimer publiquement, mais les femmes stressent beaucoup plus.
Et chaque fois que j'ai eu, et vraiment à chaque fois que j'ai eu quelqu'un qui a stressé quand je la mets face au groupe, et pourtant, c'est à chaque fois un groupe bienveillant de personnes qu'elle connaît,
c'est à chaque fois été une femme.
Et donc il faut les former un peu plus. Ok ? Donc chacun à son niveau peut faire quelque chose. Si on peut les former, ben on les forme plus.
Si on peut leur donner la parole, ben on essaie de plus leur donner la parole. Si on peut, voilà, les encourager aussi d'une manière ou d'une autre, c'est toujours bon à prendre.
Mais tu vois, par exemple, moi, à un moment donné, il y a des journalistes qui me disent : ''Oui, mais on trouve pas de femmes qui veulent parler.'' Je fais : ''Mais vous avez vu ce que vous faites à chaque fois qu'il y en a une qui ose parler ?'' C'est normal après.
Ok.
Donc c'est aussi un cercle vicieux. C'est-à-dire que si à chaque fois qu'il y en a une qui s'expose, boum, t'as la horde de cyberharceleurs qui lui tombent dessus, les autres, elles vont plus oser.
Oui, oui. Et puis aussi souvent une espèce de position comme quoi c'est pas de leur faute ou qu'ils sont complètement pas responsables par rapport à ça ou...
Non, ils ont une responsabilité.
Ouais, ouais, je sais, je sais.
Les médias ont une grosse responsabilité.
Ouais.
Et ça devrait vraiment être le quatrième pouvoir. Ça, j'y crois à fond.
Mais donc, tu disais chacun à sa position peut faire quelque chose à ce niveau-là. Enfin, vas-y, dis-moi, qu'est-ce que tu me dirais de faire ?
Qu'est-ce que tu me dirais de changer par rapport à mon traitement, par rapport à la façon dont je choisis mes invités ?
Ben toi, c'est ça. C'est-à-dire que si jamais t'as des thématiques, t'essaies toujours de trouver... tu sais, par exemple, t'as un truc qui s'appelle Expertalia.
Je sais pas si tu connais.
Je connais, ouais.
Voilà. LinkedIn. Utilise LinkedIn.
J'ai supprimé mon compte LinkedIn. Tellement je déteste ce truc.
C'est vrai ?
Oui.
Moi, j'utilise. C'est mon outil professionnel.
Mais oui. C'est... voilà, le fait que tu cites Richard Branson, le fait que tu sois dans une approche très corporate, voilà, les forty under forty, etc.
Ouais.
Je suis très allergique à tout ça en fait.
C'est vrai ?
Ouais, ouais.
Si tu veux chercher des personnes expertes, ça reste le réseau. Surtout si tu veux chercher des personnes... tu sais, les personnes justement racisées ont beaucoup plus de propension à être indépendantes.
Et l'outil de communication dans l'indépendance, c'est LinkedIn.
Hum mm.
Tu vois ? Donc c'est comme ça qu'on trouve nos clients. Et donc si tu l'as pas, tu te prives de ça.
Tu sais, c'est comme il y a des entreprises qui me disent : ''Ah, j'ai du mal à recruter des personnes à diversité.'' Et tu dis : ''Comment tu fais tes recrutements ?'' ''Ah ben, je sais pas, j'appelle des potes.''
Oui, oui, c'est ça. C'est un exemple que tu cites dans le livre aussi.
C'est la même chose. C'est-à-dire que sachant qu'il y a différents outils, ben si jamais tu veux élargir ton spectre, ben tu dois utiliser le plus d'outils possible à ta disposition.
Et tester. Moi, je suis pour le testing. Pour moi, tu testes, ça marche, ça marche pas, tu continues, tu testes autre chose. Ok ?
Ok. Oui, ben, c'est-à-dire que moi, je vais dévoiler un peu l'envers du décor, mais j'aime bien aller chercher sur ResearchGate.
J'aime bien aller chercher des personnes qui ont publié des articles de recherche sur les questions qui m'intéressent.
Hum hum.
Mais vraiment, même dans ce cas-là,
il faut trouver des personnes... Enfin, si on admet que ma...
et c'est vrai, hein, si je
cherche à travailler sur un sujet, à faire un épisode sur un sujet et que je vois plusieurs profils, je peux effectivement me dire : ''Ah ben tiens, voilà, c'est l'occasion de donner la parole à une personne.''
Mais c'est tellement inexistant, en fait, c'est tellement...
Tu peux aussi demander aux personnes que tu as déjà interviewées, s'ils connaissent des gens.
Oui, oui, mais à ce moment-là, il faut vraiment qu'il y ait chez moi une démarche vraiment ultra proactive pour dire : ''Ah non ok, bon là,
j'ai la possibilité d'interviewer très facilement tous ces hommes blancs, toutes ces femmes blanches, mais je vais leur demander plutôt de me donner l'adresse d'une personnalité qui serait plutôt racisée à ce moment-là.''
C'est ça. Tu vas pas le faire pour tous tes podcasts, je veux dire, mais c'est pas, ça prend pas tellement de temps. Enfin...
C'est déjà dur de trouver pour certains sujets. Je sais pas, je pense à un sujet comme l'intelligence artificielle ou les incels ou des choses sur lesquelles j'ai envie de travailler.
C'est déjà dur de trouver un ou une experte qui me convient.
Hum hum.
Et donc si, à côté de ça, je veux dire ok, mais j'ai en plus envie de favoriser des profils issus de la diversité.
Je te jure, c'est difficile en fait.
Non, c'est difficile, bien sûr. Il y a pas une recette magique hein.
Hum hum. Oui, bon voilà. Je continuerai à galérer, je pense hein.
Quand je te parlais, on parlait de patience.
On est arrivé au bout des septante minutes qu'on passe ensemble. Est-ce que je peux te demander ce que le futur te réserve ?
Est-ce que tu as des projets qui t'attendent encore ?
Écoute, en écrivant ce livre, je me suis rendu compte que j'adorais ça. Je pensais pas que j'allais autant aimer. Donc, je pense que j'ai deux projets de livres suivants, différents, mais voilà, je vais,
et je vais voir comment je les fais.
Et voilà. Et moi, je continue toujours à m'impliquer dans mes projets, notamment essayer de développer encore le centre qu'on a créé à Molenbeek qui s'appelle Épicerie, qui a encore besoin de pas mal de rénovations et que...
Tu peux nous en parler ?
Donc en fait, c'est un bâtiment qui était complètement délaissé à Molenbeek, qui cherchait un peu son entrepreneur.
Et donc on a décidé de l'acheter, un rêve un peu fou en se disant : Ben voilà, on va acheter ce bâtiment pour créer nos propres centres éducatifs, culturels et civiques où on a mis notre propre salle de théâtre,
où on fait nos propres ateliers avec les jeunes et on a nos bureaux aussi.
Et d'avoir vraiment un ancrage local et donc en toute indépendance. Et donc là, tu vois, tu me dis, t'es un peu allergique à ce milieu-là, mais moi, la botte au main m'approche.
Donc c'est-à-dire, tu pars d'un besoin du terrain plutôt qu'un besoin institutionnel. Parce qu'en général, c'est comme ça que se créent les centres.
C'est les politiques pensent qu'il faut faire quelque chose et puis ils décident et puis ouf, ils déroulent le truc et l'argent y va.
Ben nous, on s'est dit : Ben non, en fait, on veut partir d'un besoin de terrain. Qu'est-ce qui existe pour les jeunes ?
Qu'est-ce qui manque ? Et donc on a essayé de répondre aux besoins de ce qui manque. Et c'est devenu comme les jeunes l'ont appelé leur deuxième maison spontanément, sans qu'on dise rien.
Et voilà. Et donc on a fait tous les travaux. Moi, j'ai appris plein de choses sur les travaux d'ailleurs, un nouveau métier.
Et donc voilà, on a fait toute une série de crowdfunding, pour pouvoir l'acheter de manière indépendante.
Et puis voilà, c'est... Là, on a des subventions aussi qui tombent, donc ça, c'est cool, c'est chouette, c'est positif et on a encore plein de choses à développer. Donc voilà.
Nice. Ok. Donc ça, ça continue à être ton occupation. J'allais te dem...
C'est ça, j'essaye d'aider le plus possible. J'ai des super équipes. Il y a des super équipes là maintenant qui travaillent là-dessus.
Et ça, je trouve ça toujours important. C'est quand on a une idée de projet, ça doit jamais rester trop personnel autour de soi.
Il faut qu'il y ait d'autres personnes qui animent le truc et qui ont peut-être une autre vision, une autre façon de faire les choses.
Mais c'est OK, tant que le pourquoi, il est aligné, le reste suit.
Nice. Donc l'Épicerie reste une de tes occupations. Des projets de livres que tu veux encore garder pour toi, mais sur lesquels tu vas être occupée ces prochains mois, ces prochaines années.
Hum, j'allais te demander où est-ce qu'on peut te suivre à côté de ça, mais je pense savoir que tu préfères rester discrète et tu préfères rester, voilà, on parlait d'humilité, etc.
Je pense que ton compte Instagram, par exemple, est plutôt protégé.
Écoute, à chaque fois, je change d'avis, je le protège, puis je le remets en public. J'ai pas encore décidé. Mon compte LinkedIn est public de toute façon.
Ok.
Puis j'ai mon site, j'ai fait mon site ihsanehaouach.com. J'ai eu du mal à mettre le site ihsanehaouach.com, mais on me recommandait de le faire, mais voilà.
Waouh. On voit bien que tu préfères rester discrète et t'as une espèce d'ambivalence, d'ambiguïté à ce niveau-là hein.
Il faut faire attention, surtout au niveau privé. Voilà, j'aime bien garder ma vie privée, privée.
Très bien. Donc voilà, pour te suivre peut-être sur Instagram au moment où je publierai cet épisode, en tout cas sur LinkedIn et en tout cas sur ihsanehaouach.com.
Ihsane, merci beaucoup.
Merci à toi.
Septante Minutes passées avec toi. Et on se retrouve très bientôt pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir. Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour ces Septante Minutes avec Ihsane Haouach.
Si vous avez des commentaires très constructifs, n'hésitez pas à me les envoyer. Si ce n'est pas le cas, si vous êtes très énervé, suite à cette exposition à des questions, voilà, liées de près ou de loin
à l'islam, à l'islamophobie et au racisme,
vous n'êtes pas obligé de m'écrire, ça ne m'intéresse pas spécialement.
Le livre de Ihsane sort ce mois-ci en anglais chez l'éditeur LannooCampus et s'appelle Open Up Your Organization. J'ai mis le lien en description.
Comme je vous le disais en intro, de nouveaux épisodes sont prévus dans les semaines qui viennent. Et ça, c'est vrai, c'est certain, c'est booké.
À moins, bien sûr que, je ne sais pas, il y ait un cataclysme ou de nouveau une série d'annulations. Mais voilà, j'ai foi en mes invités.
J'espère que ça n'arrivera pas. En tout cas, ce que je peux déjà vous annoncer, c'est qu'il y a parmi ces épisodes, je crois qu'il y en a six, six enregistrements de prévus rien que pendant le mois de mai.
Hum, eh bien, il y a notamment la question des incels, qui est un sujet que je veux traiter depuis très longtemps, mais où j'ai toujours eu beaucoup de mal à trouver le bon angle, le bon invité.
Donc, j'ai trouvé un formidable professeur au Canada, quelqu'un d'anglophone, mais qui parle aussi français et avec qui on va enregistrer un épisode tout bientôt.
J'ai grand espoir qu'on arrive à produire un épisode de qualité sur ce sujet qui m'intéresse beaucoup.
Hum, je ne vais pas m'étendre là-dessus, mais je pense que c'est un sujet qui regroupe plein de questions. Voilà, questions de genre, questions de radicalisation sur Internet, questions de la neurodiversité aussi peut-être.
Et j'ai hâte de vous montrer ça. Bon, l'épisode n'est pas encore enregistré, mais j'ai bon espoir. Je vous retrouve dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir.